70
of millennials are living paycheck to
paycheck that's according to a new
survey which analyzed economic data and
census balance surveys of over 28
000 americans it found that about 54
of americans live paycheck to paycheck
but millennials
have that biggest broke energy that's
the title that they use biggest broke
energy
and 70 of them are living um paycheck to
paycheck i got to give a shout out to my
friend marcelo
talented guy comedian writer he's like
you got to talk about this broke
energy what's what's the deal with this
broke energy um
and i think basically what it is is
people love to talk crap about
millennials millennials get hated on
more than any generation
yeah i mean maybe boomers are catching
up now okay boomer okay but yeah it's
millennials for the last decade they get
hated on right they're the
you know cry babies they you know
snowflakes whatever you want to call
them but you know it's just not true
so they get hated on and they you know
it's part of this broke
energy um but by contrast seventy
percent i'm sorry seventy percent of
millennials are living paycheck to check
check
by contrast forty percent of baby
boomers
and seniors basically basically ten
thousand baby boomers turn 65
every single day so if you're going to a
65 year old's birthday coming up soon
probably your parents
yeah maybe grandparents if you're super
young they're baby boomers okay so 10
000
baby boomers turn 65 every single day
for the next
decade or two that's going to happen so
by contrast forty percent of baby
boomers and seniors live paycheck to
paycheck that's the least out of any
generation so here's the
analogy there millennials okay
they you know millennials are 30 to 40
now late
20s to 30 they're not kids anymore okay
mid-20s um
this is basically like if you're you
know i would i would equate that
the baby boomers are like the seniors in
high school exactly
millennials are kind of like sophomores
gen z kind of like freshmen like the guy
like
people a little bit younger than you
yeah who who in the office is a little
bit younger than
jesse jassy she's a gen z she's a
freshman she's getting started this is
her first job
yeah right millennial sophomores you've
been in the you know you're here for a
year
yeah gen x gen x yeah it's kind of like
a junior
yeah boomers they're seniors literally
seniors okay
so if you don't have things figured out
by senior year of high school
yeah good luck buddy if you're still
talking about making the you know
baseball team senior year
maybe sports isn't for you bro so this
is basically what i'm saying here with
um baby boomers 40 that's the least out
of any generation
no [ __ ] you've had 40 years of working
to figure it out to hopefully not be
paycheck to paycheck
but millennials are um in last place so
to give a little comfort to millennials
it doesn't help this is part of the
article it doesn't help that millennials
have faced
economic challenges one after another
since
the oldest of them graduated exactly um
in the housing crisis 2008 i was in
2007 2008 i had already graduated from
college i graduated 02. so i've already
been working for about four or five
years
right well i don't know if we want to
call it working but you know i was
i was living um so millennials kind of
got screwed they got screwed by 2008
recession you know
fast forward another uh 12 years they
get screwed by covid so basically
the pandemic threw another wrench into
their plans by giving them a second
recession and a second housing crisis
before the age of 40.
so classic millennials complaining about
all these recessions
can't catch a break the truth be told
they've had a rough go all right but
nobody feels bad like nobody feels bad
for you
because the moment you say something as
a millennial that like oh you know it's
been difficult then it's yeah
well when i was younger when i was a kid
it was even tougher yeah i had to walk
up a hill backwards barefoot in the snow
with no shoes on it's like dude that
that never happened
and what kind of child where were you
living that never happened but people
like to talk about how tough it was like
i talk about like you know if i talk to
my little nephew he's nine years old now
he's about to be none
he's got his ipad i'm like ipad you know
when i was going i had to read the whole
newspaper
i'm the exact same way with mine yeah
nephew's the exact same thing i've had
cell phone and i'm just like
play with a toy go outside i don't know
yeah
so anyway wrapping this story up so
um you know events happen to every
generation that's for sure but of course
the economy isn't fully to blame some
millennials here's the catch here
particularly six figure earners
are known to fall victim of something
called lifestyle creep
lifestyle creep and that's when one
increases one's standard of living
to match a rise in discretionary income
yikes okay so that's like saying all
right i make 50 grand a year i'm gonna
budget
i'm gonna live my best life i'm gonna
save i'm gonna invest i'm gonna you know
but now i gotta raise now i'm making 75
grand a year
so what does that mean well that's some
of that deserved mentality well i've
been working hard
i deserve a new car i deserve a rolex
i deserve to go to tulum who doesn't
want to go to tulum
so this is what happened so basically
anyway if you're living paycheck to
paycheck i feel you we can help you with
that there's a lot of stuff we're going
to be talking about right there
um but basically you know as this
lifestyle creep
creeps in like there's a lot of creeps
in south beach i'm not talking about
those crypts about lifestyle creep when
you start to make more money
you start to spend more money you feel
like you deserve
nicer things well you know i got a
roommate [ __ ] this roommate he kind of
sucks
time to live on my own right i mean
driving this you know 2004 honda accord
time to get that 20 21 beemer son you
know i kind of got this casio watch
that rolex is looking nice anyway this
is what
lifestyle creep is you start to make
more money so you start to spend more
money and here's my advice to you if
you're starting
if you're making 50 as an example now
you start making 100.
all right i'm just using easy round
numbers for one year
act like you're still making 50 grand
for one year you've been doing it for
x amount of years for one year act like
you're still
broke essentially and now that surplus
that extra 50 grand now
you're maxing out your 401k maybe you're
maxing out your roth ira
you're opening up your brokerage account
maybe you're buying a piece of real
estate property
the options are are unlimited what you
can do maybe you're investing in crypto
whatever it is
you've got way more money than you had
before
so that's what i started doing is i
start when i started making
when i went from 22 grand to 100 grand
or from 100 grand to 200 grand and 200
and so on and so forth
i lived like i was still making 22
thousand dollars and how do you fight
the temptations to not go on that trip
get
watch get that oh dude that's a great
question it's so tough you got to
understand
what the overall goal is though right
you got to understand what the overall
goal is if the overall
you know they say like um is the overall
goal to
look rich or to actually be rich
it's a big question right look i'm from
miami i live in south beach
there's a lot of people out there that
look rich broke af
broke af they're renting the rolls-royce
for the weekend
they you know they got a sick car maybe
they bought the car but they're still
living at home with their mama
they're going out and they're spending
their entire commission check on bottles
two grand
it happens this lifestyle creep it's
natural bro
it's natural the more money you make
clearly you want to spend more
right my advice to you is save that
money
act like you're still broke and um
talk to me in a few years when you're
like holy crap i've got a hundred grand
in my bank account
wow that looked out nice that to me is
the best thing ever because
um money i look at as a tool
not to buy things but to do things
right let me say that again i don't look
at money as a tool to buy things
i look at them as to do things what do i
want to do
right i go back to my chilling i want to
travel
[Laughter]
um so anyway here's actually um
something i thought about this so you
know instagram and social media talking
about this lifestyle creep
and millennials live and paycheck to
paycheck even the ones that are making
six figures i think social media has a
lot to play with this why
you want to go to you want to go to
tulum you want to go on vacation you
want to get that
internet cloud how many people go to
tulum and do not post a picture
zero yeah right like if you're going if
you're traveling you're doing
i mean you want to get that internet
class yeah you're not gonna get those
likes
you gotta get those likes i mean we all
need those likes but here's actually a
here's actually a thought that i thought
about millennials are the only
generation that i got both things going
on
stay with me here they got the social
media pressure
but they're also got money coming in
especially these people making six
figures
what does that mean they got the social
media and they got the money
okay younger generation gen z maybe you
don't have the money yet you got social
media though
so like there's a lot of younger people
that are not prone to
stunting on the gram because they don't
have any money yet they're just
they're in college they're just getting
started right right maybe they'll take
a nice selfie but they're not into loom
taking the selfie or insane bards or in
mykonos or whatever
older generations the baby boomers they
got the money
they ain't flexing on the ground grandma
grandma ain't on the ground yeah
right so millennials got got it coming
from both
ends they got the money coming in but
they also got a flex
they gotta flex you gotta flex
anyway that's the point here is that
millennials are tough so if you're
millennial out there comment
by the way give a thumbs up if you're a
millennial i know this is what pat
always does give us a thumbs up and then
when they get a
thumbs up watching that if you're not a
thumbs up thumbs down if you're a
boomer basically if you're the
if you're in between the ages of 21 and
40 give a thumbs up
if you're 40 plus 45 we'll even give you
a leeway 42 43 you're still you know
we'll call you millennial
45 plus give a thumbs down let's see
what happens there anyway that's my two
cents on why people are living paycheck
to paycheck
especially the ones that are in life
style creep all right can we move on to
our next story ready have a little fun
here
adam can i uh yeah i see a comment here
might want to
just mention this out loud but the
miller property group said uh heads up
adam your fake instagram account person
is going around dming us
wannabe sauce oh yeah let's talk about
that so here's what happens when you
when
you know all we talk is money all we
talk is money when you end up start
talking money
um scumbags follow you yeah you know i
don't mean like
follow you but like there's creepers out
there that will put
fake accounts out there and you know
talks money with two wise at the end or
three wise or
so talk money and they're gonna hit you
up and what are they going to ask for
what are they going to ask for some
bitcoin
yeah i'm not asking you for bitcoin the
only thing i'm asking you to do
is to like and comment on my pictures
because i need that validation
and i'll say that and i'm asking you to
save that money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here
to watch another click here to watch the
full episode
or just stay broke